crushing the first two games and an  amazing resourcefulness an amazing  amount of tenaciousness to keep himself  in the game and actually turn it around  yeah and Knight c4a4 seals the  Rook C2 doesn't even want to take on C6  just wants to take on A3 immediately and  there we go  F4 this bond is not going to promote  yeah but the other one is way too strong  yeah yeah that's the handshake wow  congratulations winning the match 3-0  and of course uh there was a chance here  for abdulf to bounce back it was a  fascinating game but Hikaru takes it and  secures his spot in the final yeah  congratulations to Hikaru reaching the  finals of the 960 World Championship